So, how much do you really know
about Snoopy?
There's a whole lot more to
this pup than meets the eye.
It's time to play...
First up...
do you know where Snoopy
was born?
Was it?
Don't be nervous,
you're gonna like it here.
The answer...
But, did you also know
he wasn't born alone.
How many brothers and
sisters
do you think Snoopy has?
And the answer is...
Way to go!
Think you can name them all?
Oh, hey Snoopy.
Snoopy's got a lot of talents.
Like dancing,
painting,
or going on incredible
adventures
But, can you guess his
other secret talent?
Is it?
Hey Kid!
Can I have my badminton
racket back?
Magic? I'll believe it
when I see it.
If you guessed master magician
you're right.
He's one dog that can always
learn new tricks.
And speaking of hidden
talents...
Here's a question for Charlie
Brown.
That's me!
Hey, can someone throw me the
ball?
It's true!
You've got- Wow!
I've given up two hits and
I haven't even thrown a pitch.
Say, it looks like you already
knew a lot about Snoopy.
But, there's always something
new to discover.
Thanks for playing
The Snoopy Scoop.
Only on Apple TV+